so listen I'm sure we all know what what
occurred this morning my personal
opinion is that you all know where I
stand on this do I think justice was
served
No where do I think justice is I think
this city is still old an apology and
let me digress for a moment when I came
on this job I've been a cotton now for
about 31 years when I came on this job I
came on with my honor my integrity of my
reputation if someone accused me of
doing anything that was circumvent that
then I would want my day in court
period to clear my name I've heard that
they wanted their day in court with TV
cameras so America could know the truth
but no they chose to hide behind secrecy
and broker a deal to circumvent the
judicial system my job as a police
officer is to investigate an incident
gather evidence gathered of facts and
present them to the state's attorney
that's what we did I stand behind the
detectives investigation
I'll let Mary Manuel comment further
one thing he's not only do I support the
hard work of our police officers the
defective units I'd like to remind
everybody a grand jury indicted this
individual based on a only a piece of
the evidence that the police had
collected in that period of time so a
grand jury actually brought the charges
I think on two things I'd like to serve
three things I like to say one on
financial costs this ten thousand
dollars doesn't even come close to what
the city spent in resources to actually
look over the camera gather all the data
gather all information that actually
brought the indictment by the grand jury
I'm many many multiple different charges
second is what I would call the ethical
cost and the ethical cost is you have as
a person who was in the House of
Representatives legislation that dealt
with hate crimes putting him on the
books that President Obama then signed
into law to then use those very laws and
the principles and values behind the
Matthew Shepard hate crimes legislation
to self-promote your career is a via as
a cost that comes to all the individuals
gay men and women who will come forward
and one day to say they were a victim of
a hate crime who now will be doubted
people of faith Muslim or any other
religious faith will be a victim of hate
crimes
people that of also of all walks of life
and backgrounds race ethnicity sexual
orientation
now this cast a shadow of whether
they're telling the truth and he did
this all in the name of self-promotion
and he used the laws of the hate crime
legislation that all of us collectively
over years have put on the books to
stand up to be the values that embody
what we believe in this is a right wash
of justice
[Applause]
[Music]